the united states has evacuated some 120
000 people from afghanistan in recent
weeks many of them afghan nationals the
majority are hoping to end up in the u.s
but for now
some have ended up in the balkans
hundreds of evacuees found themselves
flying from kabul to places such as
kosovo north macedonia and albania
the biden administration has asked those
countries to host asylum seekers while
their visas are being processed
a plane carrying 150 afghans arrived in
albania early on monday the new arrivals
brought the total number of afghan
evacuees in the balkan country to just
over 600.
[Music]
let's bring in dw's fanny pachar here
who joins us from the albanian capital
tirana good to see you fanny
albania it's agreed to take in 4 000
refugees i understand or s or evacuees
at least but only temporarily what's the
story there
well that's exactly the question that a
lot of people ordinary albanians ask
what that word temporarily actually
means officially it means that as long
as the people who are arriving from
afghanistan
either the adoha via the uia
who came directly from kabul are going
to be vetted
at least this process is going to take
one year until everything is clear that
they really deserve to say so to receive
a u.s visa that they really qualify for
united states visa to then move on to
the united states but there is
capitalism here in albania among some
who say is this really the time to trust
the united states given the way the
chaotic way they say the way the u.s has
left afghanistan after two decades of
fool so there are a lot of questions as
far as this process is concerned the
vetting process and how long this
actually is going to take and also what
is going to happen to those afghan
refugees who do not qualify for a us
visa and are basically going to be
stranded there here in albania
now i understand you've been talking to
some of those afghan evacuees yourself
uh there in toronto what have they been
telling you
well they were basically researching
themselves where albania is located
prior to their arrival in fact we have
spoken to one afghan refugee and it's
quite difficult to speak to afghan
refugees here because they're shielded
by police from the press from media
officially saying because of kovi but
also because they just arrived obviously
from afghanistan so they're really
protected this one afghan refugee we
have spoken to in particular said once
he realized albania is a safe country
compared to afghanistan at least he told
his family let's go this is the plane we
should we should take and go to toronto
to the capital city but he also made
clear that his hope is that he's going
to move on to the united states very
soon in fact to him that word
temporarily means a couple of days here
in albania or maximum a couple of weeks
let's have a look at our report
the albanian coastline of tourists
tourists are wrapping up their summer
holidays some hotels have opened up for
refugees from afghanistan
for the children moments of joy in a
country unknown to them
others are housed in college dorms like
this one in albania's capital tirana
third floor
the third floor yes yes
arrived on monday
i searched firstly this in internet that
where is it located
which countries are its neighbors after
that i tell all the my family member
that albania is very good country the 22
year old was able to leave the chaos of
afghanistan behind with his family of
ten
albania is a nato member and didn't
hesitate to agree to the us request to
host afghan refugees
street signs named after u.s presidents
here underlying the role of the united
states as a patron of stability in the
balkans
this street for example has been renamed
after donald trump now the u.s as a
partner towards progress is deeply
ingrained in people's minds here
regardless of whether any actual headway
is being made or not albania is
struggling to make the case to its own
citizens they are split over the issue
of accepting afghan refugees
we have an economy where people are
begging we have to search for bread in
the trash you know
they are humans like everyone else and
albanians were once refugees
so
we have to support them opportunity
caring favor with the us may help
albania a non-eu member to tighten its
relationship with the west
but security researcher al-bandafa says
the government's lack of transparency
about their deal with america will fuel
animosity towards afghans albania can
handle temporarily hosting
afghan citizens what to do
and how to best
accommodate the needs of those potential
refugees that are going to be stranded
in albania hambik sadiq is hopeful that
he will be able to go to the united
states soon after all
this is what everyone is being promised
here
they must carry us
to other country that is
u.s
that's a hope everyone here seems to
share to leave this place and go to
america but it's unclear when or who
will make it the vetting process for the
us can take a year or more
now obviously albanians themselves here
are asking why is albania taking in
afghan refugees given the very own
volatile situation in this country when
you look at its economy but also when
you look at its political instability
they just need to look back at the
current election this spring the way it
played out for the third time the rama
government one but the turmoil that was
revolving around that election clearly
tells you albania is a quite unstable
country within this region itself now
the u.s of course is seen here as a
guarantor of stability we have heard it
also in the report if you look back at
its history of force and animosity here
in this region the question though is
what is albania then is hoping to gain
from all of this now
various analysts are discussing this
very question as more afghan refugees
arriving around 600 are already here
about 4 000 are expected not only here
in albania but also in the neighboring
countries kosovo and north macedonia if
you ask me personally albania also wants
to stand for some good news that they
are actually helping people while the eu
is discussing how to deal with african
refugees and how to best keep actually
refugees per se out of the european
union specific right now afghan refugees
so albania wants to matter again also on
the international stage but then the
question really is whether that
political hope that is not officially
discussed here but is it officially
between the lines whether the uh this
country is going to achieve to in a way
start accession talks with the eu and
have a closer relationship with the west
okay so the evacuees from afghanistan
are in albania through a deal with the
us
fine but what about the people in
albania itself how do they view this
action
albanians traditionally if you look at
the kosovo war two decades ago more than
half million people have been sheltered
here in albania albanians are
traditionally very welcoming when it
comes to helping any foreigner in fact
but when it comes to this uh situation
right now they ask various questions is
it really the time to trust
for to the united states as i've
liberated earlier but also what is going
to happen to those who are going to be
stranded here so a lot of albanians
regardless whether they're actually
welcoming or not are saying the
government here is not sharing enough
information it is not transparent enough
about this exact deal and the details of
this deal between the united states and
albania
barney thank you very much uh that was
our correspondent fanny pachar there in
tirana